Donald Trump has now turned on his darling
former press secretary Kaylee mcinanny in a
Bonkers truth social rant truth Central
Donald Trump trothing to Central quote
Kaylee milk toast mcananny now what oh god
I'm gonna get back to this he writes milk
toast like you would make a piece of toast
with milk like Japanese milk bread okay
um this is not the word this is not the spelling
of milk toast but we'll get back to that Kaylee
milk toast macanoni just gave out the wrong
poll numbers on Fox news I am up 30 I am 34
points up on De sanctimonious not 25 up while
25 is great it's not 34. she knew the number
was corrected upwards by the group that did the
poll the rhinos and globalists can have her Fox
News should only use real stars so let's look at
this in pieces first of all the word is milk toast
m-i-l-q-u-e it has a couple of definitions timid
Meek or unassertive lacking in character or vigor
um milk toast like we would talk about bread is
something different altogether although it is
delicious I will admit that Japanese milk bread if
you toast it it is really something else so let's
talk about the strategy the strategy to the extent
that there is one is Trump turning on everyone
for any reason at all if they don't do the
metaphorical bow down and pray at the altar
of trump in this particular case Kaylee mcinanny
just gave polling numbers that Trump feels are
different or inaccurate or were revised in some
way it doesn't seem like this is a good strategy
for two different reasons number one if you are
going to immediately viciously turn on anyone not
even for criticizing you but just for reporting
polling data that may be disfavorable in some
way to you or not as favorable as you want it
to be uh you are going to very quickly run out
of allies because you're going to end up turning
on a lot of different people and secondly it runs
the risk of alienating other former staffers even
if Trump if you're a trump former Trump staffer
and I don't know maybe you'd be involved in his
2024 campaign maybe you wouldn't if you see Trump
turning on other former staffers for essentially
nothing are you going to be ready and willing to
defend Trump to work for Trump to help Trump in
any way it seems like the answer is no now this
is just this is a very funny thing um Kaylee
mcinanny was hosting something on Fox news I
guess maybe she has a show now on Fox News I don't
even remember and Congressman chip Roy uses the
word milk toast as a reference to the fact that uh
Trump called her milk toast this this is actually
a little bit funny starting with you Congressman
chip Roy what is the realistic alternative to this
because I understand we wouldn't formally default
we can pay the interest on our debt but our debt
could be downgraded and that could be catastrophic
so what is the realistic alternative to this deal
well thanks Kaylee uh first of all you know
the everything that we're seeing out of the
bill that was put forward this this deal this
hatch this weekend is pretty milk toast if uh
if that word might mean something to you but
frankly uh the real problem we've all right
so very very clever there chip Roy um the more
Trump turns on former staffers the more likely
it is that his 2024 campaign will be made up of
even more incompetent staffers which actually
sounds very fun to me even if it's not going to be
a particularly good strategy for winning in 2024
so Kaylee mcinanny the latest Trump staffer former
staffer to see Trump turn on them and remember
Trump's idea of loyalty is you never criticized
Trump okay you never questioned Trump's judgment
all right you always praise Trump anytime his name
comes up it's getting a little difficult you don't
even report polling data that Trump doesn't like
that's a tough standard for loyalty that is a
genuinely tough standard for loyalty it's going
to be tough to keep that one up particularly if
desantis's rise in the polls over the last 10
days is not a blip and it is a new change of
Direction but we will follow it after the break
Joe Biden's sexual assault accuser Tara Reid has
defected to Russia do you know anything about
Russia they asked me and I said I don't know
anything about it well that's where Joe Biden's
sexual assault accuser has uh defected to we're
going to talk a lot more about believe all women
in the context of this defection stay tuned